a lot of people when when traveler
became successful hoped that it was it
signaled some sort of change in country
music uh I think it was just uh I don't
know if I've fought back on that I and I
don't know that I'm not I don't see
myself as some kind of fighting the good
fight guy you know like I think a lot of
people I think that's a thing that gets
made up in media and culture where one
thing is right and one thing is wrong
and yeah but you know I always feel like
if you don't like one kind of music or
the other it's just not for you
obviously there's lots of people who'd
like other kinds of music even within
the realm of what we call country today
so I'm only worried about what I'm doing
and what I'm trying to do or how I
present music that and I just try to do
things I want to listen to and I think
that's what everybody else is trying to
do too yeah like I may be somewhere
somebody's trying to do things just
because they think it will get played on
the radio or make money or something
like that but those things rarely get
played on the radio or make money
yeah you know I think you're making it
for the wrong reasons mm-hmm invention
that catches up with you did you ever
did you ever I mean in all the songs you
wrote did you ever write a song to get
played on the radio to get played on
radio well I mean when you're a
songwriter that's part of your job yeah
yeah this is to write those songs and so
you know how they're made I know how
they're made and I but also you know
know that there's two kinds of songs you
can have on the radio there's there's a
song that can be a hit and there's a
song that can move the needle and be
impactful for an artist and what's the
difference I don't know the difference
that's the thing
but you always just try to make
something that doesn't seem for me you
always try to be as timeless as you can
be
I think timeless is a word that you try
to inject into music that sometimes men
that's right maybe it sounds like I'm
I'm not knocking song hugs that are hits
for the sake of being hits we need the
hits for the second beam heads yeah
because they pay for the move the needle
songs yeah you know it and I get it and
they're all part of the same wheel you
know and they're not once not good and
evil ones not bad or you know everybody
likes to listen to songs just because
it's fun nobody wants to sit around him
and listen to I really have to analyze
these lyrics songs all the time mm-hm
we need both well yeah you you need
great you need great pop songs right I
mean and and there's an art to a great
pop song absolutely right if there
wasn't everybody be doing it right right
and you can and you and you know how
hard it is to do it it's extremely hard
to write a hit song and anybody that
thinks it's easy just hasn't done it
mm-hmm and it pays well enough they'd be
doing it is it good it's a lot of people
who've tried I'm saying